Europe will not be built all at once, nor
in an overall construction,
it will be achieved through concrete achievements,
first creating de facto solidarity
this declaration by Robert Schuman has
become a landmark a beacon
the occasion to celebrate the  europe every
year on the same date on may 9
72 years later the citizens take
center stage and the conference on
the future of europe submits its final report
this conference is also done step
by step for more than a  year to
overcome many obstacles
time constraints the distances to
cover
the scope and complexity of the subjects
the languages ​​the pandemic and
travel restrictions she
reinvented the participatory method with
a multilingual digital platform
open to all other
national and European citizens' panels and a
plenary assembly bringing together citizens
and elected officials on an equal footing the
tens of thousands of
citizens,
young and old, have  took the
floor deliberated on their priority
that of the union they expressed themselves
on how they saw their europe
they traced the paths for the future
of europe they tabled hundreds
of ideas and proposals for
achievements  they have imagined
all sorts of new forms of solidarity
they have recreated trust
the institutions of the european union
have also been strongly mobilized
by taking part in discussion tables in
the four corners of europe
today it is not  the end but the
beginning of something a new
phase in policy-making
that strengthens the voice of citizens at the
heart of the european union
message received the future belongs to us